Now let's see how well this works when we
have something like a branch that is just always
taken. In that case, the entry for that branch
will just be all ones in the history. That branch
has a fixed PC. It always has the same
history. When we XOR them, we will be using only
one 2-bit counter. So pretty much, although we have
a long history, if the branch is just a repetition
of the same thing, we are ending up using
only one of the 2-bit counters. So the additional cost,
relative to just having an array of 2-bit counters,
is that now we are keeping an 11-bit history for
this branch. So still the cost is not just
2-bits, it's really, let's say 11 or 16-bits plus 2,
but it's much less than a long history plus
2 to the Nth times a 2-bit counter. If we
have a branch that is never taken, we can do
the same reasoning and end up using a single counter.
If we have a branch that has something like NT,
NT, it really only has two possible histories, zero one,
zero one, zero one, etcetera or one zero, one zero,
one zero, etcetera. So it ends up using two counters.
So if we have a lot of these counters as
you can see, most branches are going to be like these.
We will be using very, very few entries
by these branches, which leaves us plenty of counters
for branches where we have a very long
pattern. Where we will be using something like, you
know, 16 histories and thus use something like
16 counters. As you can see in this organization
pretty much, the branch is that need more
counters get them; branches that need relatively few counters
get them. The only really additional cost
relative to just having the counters is
the histories. The downside is that again,
some branches with particular histories might overlap in
which counter they use, with other branches
and other histories. Pretty much, my branch
XOR with its history, might map to the same counter as some other branch, and
its own history, when they're XOR. But this happens very rarely
if the BHT is large, and now it can be large because each entry is just 2-bits.